I thought about the truck that you took
good good morning and how'd I have an
influence on the movie so I was just
wondering at what point after that
experience do you think there's a movie
here that I want to make you know the
the summer that Britt and I spent on the
road sort of changed our lives and it
was something that sort of it was like
being electrocuted that sizzle lasted
for a long time and it was hard for us
to shake and so we put in it we put
elements from that summer into the rope
we made which was the East you know sort
of a braided rope and that's just one
thread I was wondering well there any
other names being bandied about before
you arrive at the east or was that
always the plan although well for a long
time we called it the West okay you got
such a great cast in this film so I was
just wondering is this your first this
your first choice cast and how long did
it take for that chemistry to manifest
itself because it looked very convincing
well yeah we try not to have a first
choice or second choice or third choice
because I think that eliminates all the
interesting choices that can come your
way by people who are moved by the
script we really wanted the script to be
a litmus test and let you know the
people that were excited by the material
come to us and then you know meet them
and that was so great when we got to see
people's eyes light up when they talked
about their specific characters you know
like Toby Kebbell I remember being on
the phone with him actually so I felt
his eyes light up over the phone but him
talking about the dock and I was like
wow I got off the phone I'd be like wait
to be so lucky if we got this guy to
play the dock I mean and you know gosh
if I had imagined another actor when we
were writing it or or had tried to go
for someone else then I would have
missed
Toby's amazing performance there
definitely completely embody the
characters because I've heard somewhere
that you always you always get the
actors sort of changed their own lines
which I thought was quite interesting to
play the script is very tightly knit so
how much change is there from the sort
of initial screenplay to what actually
transpired is also going
you know I've always done this
instinctively and then I saw there was
Woody Allen has there's a four-hour
documentary on Woody Allen and actually
I was watching it at night when we were
shooting the East I would come home and
watch 15 minutes of it which was made
sense but he said he'll he says just
make it work make it sound real you know
and I feel the same way it's like look
we're telling a story I mean I'm not
married to the words I'm not a wordsmith
I'd be a novelist then I'm a filmmaker
and a storyteller and that's a organic
live process so you know the actors know
their characters better than I know
their characters if they have a great
way of saying something more power to
them I feel like we're all excavators
and we get together on set and we just
dig you know and anyone can strike gold
at any moment and I think that if
everybody on the crew feels like at any
moment they could strike gold then
there's a much better feeling at work
every day yeah ya know I think you know
the great cost and the stars got in
particular magnetically like them I also
got asked the for the East the ends
justify the means so I was willing how
much do you agree with that philosophy
in that has it been anything that you've
done or for you the ends of justified
the means I think that ends justifying
the means are always tricky tricky sport
I sometimes think that it's better to
live a life where you're making a
conscious solid choice every day but it
leads to somewhere not so great then you
know making shady choices every day or
accepting shady things in order to get
to some great place in another darkness
hands I thought this could have been a
completely different genre of film
because the message is so strong and the
issues are so strong so what made you
decide to go about this as a thriller
and how did you go about crafting the
suspense there's a couple of sequences
there where I was really suspenseful
well I don't know if you've been
following Edward Snowden but she's the
whistleblower and the United States
who's now on the run and he's going to
you know different places he was in Hong
Kong you know Moscow who knows where he
is
but that feels like us
five thriller to me so I feel like real
life these days feels like a spy
thriller or thriller and so that feels
like the most natural genre to be making
films and for me at least I've got one
final question and they think I mean
obviously these are issues you feel very
strongly about there's anything that you
hope audiences will take away with them
or you just happy to provoke discussion
on on the issues yeah I always say that
this is a movie that you should see with
someone you're sleeping with if you wake
up the next morning and you're talking
about it and we've done we've done part
of our job right then
you